everybody out miles I'm here with Jim
fallows who you are incredible and you
wrote this fascinating article for the
Atlantic and have a really interesting
discussion with Bill about it I want to
know what it's been like since you're at
the article and you mentioned that you
can get a lot of feedback from members
of the military and
so I've worked for the Atlantic for a
long time 35 years of this is by far the
most response I've ever gotten for any
article medicine post being surprised me
in two ways one is it's void thousands
now most are very welcome bows where he
thought hole very disturbing in some
ways that's one volume is one thing the
fact that has mainly been for people in
the military there's a second probably
ninety percent of people who need an
active duty now or loosing veterans and
the third has been how supportive they
have been at the basic argument which is
there's something fundamentally wrong
with military and the civilian
population these days well it's hard to
read that article or not agree with what
you're saying there which is that it is
a system that is very hard to criticize
and appears to be in many ways broken or
in need of fixing and you I would have
I was afraid initially that many people
read any military connection will take
oh this is criticizing us we're gonna
have to have some tribal revolts from
against us but in fact just the opposite
there's been part of my argument is
stories we need to have a more engaged
discussion what's good about the
American military and what's weak and
bad and that's exactly the spirit in
which many people in the military have
responded but just yesterday I've done
now like almost twenty of these around
to response on the Atlantic site
somebody said why are you only hearing
from people in the military we're hoping
to some people who are part of the gym
will
it also say we're gonna engage in these
discussions self my hope would be the
next round of political campaigns or
media attention to have some attention
some focus on this institution that
takes trillions of our dollars per year
and that that takes people's lives and
then just has all the impact that does
around the world so I feel some modest
encouragement with this kind of response
that's excellent I mean it's not just an
article that you have up there on the
Atlantic there's a whole discussion
going on that you're moderating and
curating I'm there and it's really
interesting what are some examples of
the feedback one that I put up just
today just before coming on the show was
from somebody who was a young marine
captain who had been a couple of tours
in Afghanistan in the rock
they said he was going to explain why he
was going to resign his commission
leaving languor he said that when he was
leading his soldiers in Kandahar and
Afghanistan he said there's no military
reason for them to be there was simply
for his marine commander to show off for
the Marines could do absent army could
control and actually he was saying that
about Helmand and he said that all the
focus should be on Kandahar and this was
an example of something that should have
been much more in the focus of public
attention
I was inter-service rivalry sort of
wasting all this time wasting wives
waste
money science didn't want to be under
the command of the armies yes have their
own sort of Potemkin village showing
what they could do even though in the
larger interest you know didn't make
makes make sense and so he was saying
the Marines he was commanding gave their
lives for something they're just
inter-service jealousy and he said this
sickened him and he was leaving the
career at Iwo I don't mean to single
this guy out even though I know his name
which I've concealed for the leaders
puts a sign of how seriously the 1% of
America that's in the uniform takes
these life-and-death issues that need to
be recognized by the rest of the party
well thank you so much for highlighting
these issues in such a really
fascinating way I would completely
recommend going on the Atlantic and
seeing this discussion that's taking
place Jim Palace really imaginative
thank you very much